[Musique]
le trouble bipolaire n'a rien de
romantique et des artistes acceptent de
plus en plus d'en parler on sait pas du
tout comment tu sais que le trouble de
santé mentale quand on est réellement
dans une phase dépressive clinique qu'on
n'arrive pas à se lever de son lit qu'on
l'ait constamment invité par des cycles
de pensées suicidaires
je vois pas comment ce serait possible
de créer quelque chose
florence k était hospitalisé en 2011
pour un grave épisode dépressif et
psychotique en 2010 est le diagnostic
tombe troubles bipolaires en période
maniaque
quand on est survolté quand y en a trop
la concentration peut pas être là il ya
trop de pensée qui se bousculent dans la
tête je sais très bien que je n'ai pas
choisi cette maladie chaque personne
atteinte de troubles bipolaires a une
histoire différente
l'ancienne animatrice de musiqueplus
varda étienne était parfois
dysfonctionnelle à cause de ces épisodes
de manille et de dépression a vite en
train de s'écrouler carrément je perdais
ça m'a coûté mon premier mariage entre
autres j'ai une certaine confiance en
moi que je deviens kerry grâce à la
manille mais il ya l'autre aussi le côté
de la médaille qui fait que lorsque je
suis en phase dépressive de la maladie
là c'est l'enfer environ 2% de la
population vit avec un trouble bipolaire
dont les artistes kanye west et mariah
carey au québec les témoignages de mara
tremblay de françois massicotte le
missionne l'embarras et de michel
courtemanche ont permis de mieux
comprendre la maladie
personnellement j'en ai fait ma mission
c'est vraiment très important pour moi
parce que je pense qu'en tant que
personnalité publique
j'ai une certaine responsabilité et puis
surtout je suis éliminé les tabous
l'organisme en relief offre du soutien
aux personnes vivant entre autres avec
la bipolarité la libération de la parole
chez des artistes a eu un impact énorme
les artistes ont carrément sauver des
vies des gens qui nous ont appelés
nausée moi je sont rangées au suicide et
le fait d'entendre parler de florence k
qui dit moins ça m'a aidé de me faire
aider
c'est comme au quai par où je commence
donc oui on sourit
car bien d'avoir un deuxième enfant et l
étudiant en psychologie
grâce à la médication au soutien
psychologique et à de saines habitudes
il ya une vie après le diagnostic aya
une ville qui a une vie en tout cas dans
mon cas encore plus belle
ici louis philippe ouimet radio-canada
mourir
[Musique]